W:OOHH hey! Hey there!
B: H-Hey buddy!
B: Hey how's it going?
M: Okay, I'm glad you guys are having so much fun there. HA. HA. HEE. HO.
W: Oh hey, there's-there's Mark.
M: Hang on, I'm here...
M: Hello, who- who's that  over there? Is that to the right?
B: That's me. That's me. that's me to the right. W:That 's Bob
M: Hellooooooo,
W: I'm to your left. M: Helloooooo
B: I'm gonna give you a Casey Neistat wave
B: This is how he waves to people?! *Words turn to laughter*
*Everyone laughs*
M: Helloooooo...
B: Alright so what are we d- What are we doing here?
W: So first we have to press this red button...
B: OK W: ...And then, it starts the map
W: So now we have to open this box, get a grenade out, and throw it at each other
M: Alright, easy peasy!
B: Oh god    W: nrg.. No where are you going, W-where? WHYYY is r- hand that way!
M: You know shouting about your own failures is maybe entertaining for some people but for professional gamers like me we don't care. W:*gibberish*
M: No! Its t- What are you talkin' about? ME?
W: That's all you've done for 6 years-- M: Noooooooooo!
M: I shout about my successes
M: And my successes are that I'm gonna blow your ass away
B: I- I- Having never played this game before I feel like I'm at a distinct disadvantage
M: *laughs* Don't worry, It's really... *fades into more laughter*
M: Oh you can left click-- There goes my frames again! It's two frames!
M: Oh- It's back, nevermind
W: Why- Why're you having issues?
M: It's two frames!! Aahh! I've turned to jello!! Hang on!
M: Wait- What the- What??
*wade yelling*
W: Oh no, it didn't go very far
M: You actually threw it- Uh *explosion, scream from wade* W- whaaa??? *Mark and Bob laugh*
M: I got two frames! Two fra- Two f- Two- Two frames!
W: I like how my stats are pretty bad but like Marks, 0 wins, 0 kills, 2 deaths
M: Oh please, you have 18 deaths!
W: I do- M: You can't exactly the proportionality is--
M: ooouuuyyuooouyouuo
W: Hey, 14 of my deaths are *unintelligible*
B: Oh no! I c- Fucking close the thing!- God-
B: I hate all of you
M: what, you hate all- What did I do to you??
M: I'm just tryna play a nice friendly game of grenade!
*Bob in background* I... hate... all of you
M: Hang on-- I'm about.. I'm about to blast your ass from here to Timbuktu
B: Nah nah nah nah nah nah nah... M: Right... quickly... FRAMES! FRAMES!!
M: Frames! Frames! FrAames! Frames! FRAAAMEZ! B: Is there a more convenient way to raise the *unintelligable*
M: FRAAMES! W: One of Mark's arms is just gone.. *laughter*
*Mark yelling frames aggressively*
M: There we go, I'm back now.. apparently
M: I don't know why that happens
B: uh- u- uh- hang on- W: Mark, where is your left arm??
M: Don't worry about it, it's right in front of me
M: You don't need to worry about where my arm is, worry about where your arm is.
W: I'm dead
M: Yeah, I know, see? Maybe you should- shoulda worried about where your arm was
W: I- M: sTuPiD
B: Can I not pull the pin once I pick this up? I don't understand
M: You gatta put yer finger in the pin
M: FRAMES! frames! FRaAaHaAmES! *laughter* FRAMES!!
M: K. We're back- FFRRAAMMEESS!!!
M: Hang on- Wait- No- It's fine.
M: FRAMES- uhuhh- Frames! WHY? FRAME-RATE!
M: WHY FRAME-RATE? WHY FRAME-RATE GO BAD?
M: WHY DO I HAVE NO FRAMES?? WHAT IS THIS SHIT?
*Bob and Wade laughing*
M: Oookay
M: Well I guess I win!
M: Why do I have no frames?!
M: Are you tellin' me they didn't optimize this game
to be high quality- W: Does this look like the kind of game that they would optimize??
M: YESS!!!! I played this game before and it was perfectly fine!
M: It's only when I join YOU assholes!!
W: It's perfectly fine for me!! M: It's not fine for me!
M: Hang on im gonna- Ima restart the game
I'm gettin outta here! Screw you guys!
Screw each and every one of you guys
All of you at the same time
Screw You
B: Wh- How do we restart the- How do we play it again? W: I do it
M *mocking*: Ohhhh Wade does it
Oh, okaay.
W: Well I hosted the server what do you think-- M: Ohh Wade does it
Oh, okaay. W: Hey how are your frames?
M: They're better now! I'm- I restarted the game and it's definitely better
W: You don't wanna yell "FRAMES! FrAaAMeS!" for 10 more minutes?
M: What's wrong with me- m- I'm telling you guys of a problem and you guys- you guys
should be like more understanding
W: Hey! You didn't care about my issues! So I don't care about yours
M: I don't care about your issues!
W: I don't care about yOuRs!
M: Well you ShOuLD!
W: No I shouldn't! You having issues is better for me!
M: No it's not I'm pu- It- du- Obviously not! I had a ton of issues and you still died!
M: So who- *burps* -'s fault is this?
Did we start? I'm pushin my button.
Alright. Get ready
Cause you guys
Are donezo.
By the way I know you guys were concerned but the frames are-
BAD- BAD- FRAMES fa- frames!
WHYY?? Why- This is not fair!
*Bob laughing* M: This is very clearly not fair!
M: Why are you guys ruining my frames?!
W: Bob and I decided to get together, earlier, and, take away your frames.
M: hhah god dammit
M: G- I can't- I can't-- I cAnT- I can't. I can't, I can't.
M: Maybe it's the multistream. Maybe  m- maybe- maybe watching the multistream
is causing this-- Ima turn off the multistream, ima go back in the game
It's still crappy-- AAH! NOoOoO!
hOw DiD tHaT-
bUT i- but! I didn't even pull the pin!
M: But I didn't pull the pin!
whoa W: Where'd bob go?
M: Bob? *explosion*
M: Well.
W: Bob's muted by the way. I don't' know if you know that.
B0:Hello
B: Hello W&M: Hello
M: I- I- I need to- I'll be right back
M: Hang on, I'm turning the graphics quality to very low
*Sad piano music plays* W: Did you hear about that guy who had bad frame issues? What a loser
B: What an iDiOt
M: Ok I've got good frames right now but I have a feeling that's gonna stop
*W&B Laughing* W: We'll find out, I'm sure we'll hear about it if you do
M: Yea Whatever man. I feel like I should be able to share with my friends...
The problems that I'm having and you guys are just like nnnnnnnnnnnnnn
M: Fr- Oh right when I go for trying to put the pin in...
M: It frame drops, everything's fine until I try to pull the- I pulled the pin
M: Hang on wait, I gotta throw it, throw it, throw it
M: LET GO
M: LEEETTT GGGGOOOOO
M&B laugh
*Mark's horror of realizing that he didn't record the game immediately sets in*
M: I didn't even show the game. I didn't even show the game to people. I didn't even show the game.
*Wade laughs* *Bob laughs while saying* He, didn't, even, have, the game, on, screen
M: I'm such a bad let's player, I'm so bad, I'm so bad, I'm just the worst
M: I can't do anything right. I c-, why don't' I get any frames
hang on I'm looking it up, hang on I'm looking it up. Good bye game, I'm looking it up. Help
M: please, somebody help.
M: Ok there's two fixes, I'm gonna do this real quick and then we are gonna play a real good game in heren
M: and I'm gonna beat you guys, right?
W: Bob you're muted again, I don't' know if you meant to be.
B growls: NO
*W&M laugh*
B: I haven't- I haven't done anything yet. *M&W still laughing* B: So I don't know..
B: What you're so worked up about Mark
M: It's just funny man, I'm just laughing man, laughing
M: HA HA HA HA
B: That's *unintellgible* W: *screaming* OH NO, NOT AGA-HA-hain!
*Bob laughs*
B: I'm just over here trying to jam it in the hole and Wade's killing himself for me, I appreciate that
W: I'm a master of the pin. But a failure of the throw
M: Yea, yea, yea ,yea,yea
M: I can't even get any, get any frames... W: Just FRAMES, FRAMES
m: oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, ok, alright, ok, alright, ok, alright, ok
W: Mark's master of the FRAMES
M: alright, ok, you know what...
W: Know what? M: I don't know man.
M: Wait, wait, we've got a fix, a start a new one.
B: Hang on, I gonna get the pin out!
M: Start a new one
W: As Soon as Bob lets me I'll restart it. M: Cut him off. Cut him Off. Start a new one
M: Once Bob gets in here. I got another idea. Ok now
B: Hello M: Ok now restart it. Apparently that fixes it. W: done
M: Ok and now apparently this should be all good. So I should be good to go here.
M: Alright, smooth so far, smooth sailing W: I'm ready
M: Smooth sailing so far. Oh yea, this is smooth as butter. This is smooth
M: Nnaahhhh, goddamn it. There goes my frames. OH
W: What happening M: THROW IT! THROW IT! THROW IT! THROW IT! THROW IT!
M: Oh W: I DID IT
M: oh, goodbye guys
W: See ya dude
W: How's your frames *Bob laughs* *Mark laughs*
B: How's your frames you f#$&ing dick
*Mark laughs harder* B: You know how my f*%&ing frames are you f$*@ing dick
M: You know Wade I*wade tries to interrupt* feel like at some point, at some points we used to be friends...
M: who cared about each other and who supported each other when we're low
M: And had problems and know I feel like you are just smacking me when I'm down.
W: Oh, bro M: wha, don't bro me
W: Dude, bro. M: what, what, what
W: man it's- B: man, are you dude bro-ing him right now.
W: Dude no, bro
M: Alright, I'm watching you. My frames are good now.
M: I don't know why. Now that I'm not playing
M: Yea Wade, for me your left hand just isn't, your whole left arm is gone
B: I feel like my pin is not... My pin does not want to do the thing
M: I found like shaking the grenade around, the pin just naturally falls out. W: Oh damn it. that was my secret
W: I wasn't gonna tell you guys. I just grab the grenade, shake it like crazy till the pin falls out then I just launch it. Like that
B: OH FUCK *W&M laugh* B: Nailed it
*More Laughing* M: Yea, pretty good, pretty good, pretty good
M: I'm already dead, *pausing to contemplate whether he wants to say Wade or not* BOB!
M: You don't need to blow my ass up anymore.
W: I read online that blowing Mark up once he's dead will fix his frames
M: No, I've got even worse frames
B: This is really not a good game to play for the first time on stream
*Mark laughs*
B: Ok, got it
W: Why is this... B: Let me get this into a throwing position
W: *Says "shut up" in Wadese*
B: And then violently shake it, and then... W: yes B: HUH
M: Wow B: Where did it go? Where'd it go M: Well it didn't go near B: Oh NO
*everyone laughs*
M: you guys are gonna go down. My frames are good
W: We're gonna go down just like your frames. M: No I think it's you shaking your grenade, I think that's what's doing it
M: Cause I kept getting low frames everytime someone was shaking your grenade
W: You got low frames before I even got a grenade
M: No, no, are you shaking?
W: No, I don't have a grenade yet M: yo, did you grab a grenade? W: No I don't have a grenade
M: See that's the problem, you cant' grab a grenade. My frames. My frames *Wade laughs and mutter incomprehensibly* M: MY FRAMES!
M: Oh the pin's out! Go! I choose you grenade!!!
M: I choose you! I CHOOSE YOU!
(GRENADE uses BLOW UP on MARKIPLIER!) M: Duh
W: are you gotta be kidding me? *Bob swears alot*
W: YES YES YES M: wait, wait how'd you kill me?
M: How'd you kill me? W: I threw a grenade at you, you dumb shit M: No, you, you, you...
M: You sabotaged my game
B:I- I- I can't make my grenades throw to save my goddamn life
M: I can't make frames to save My damn life
M: Maybe it's just the gren- no it was the surgery one too
M: I don't know what's going on.  I have perfectly fine fram- right now everyone wave their arms as hard as you can
W: Heeyyy *Bob makes cartoonish noises*
M: I've got great frames, great frames, great frames all day, great frames, all day great frames baby
Mark: great frames, great frames, great frames, great frames, W: grape frames, okay, very good- very good- that's good M: great frames, great frames,
M: Grape frames.
*Mark groans* M: Everytime you grab a grenade!!!
*wade laughs M: It's a god damn- it's YOU
M: It's you!!! Everytime you grab the grenade, everytime I... W: Oh NO
M: Oh I hope you dye
*Wade scream* B: Oh god WHAT
M: Ah, oh, oh, oh, look a the guys with no frames
M: Look a the good winning guy with no frames
B: Seriously, how do you throw anything W: that's cause you can't grab anything
B: I don't understand M: I GRABBED, I have a grenade, I have- oh, shit
M: I can't make it frames. B: I can't, Oh No OnE cAreS
M: EVERYONE CARES
M: I can't, why's my button, why's my lid op- what? My lids already open
B: Oh wow wow, Marks fucking cheating. hang on
W: Yea I agree M: My lid, my lid is very open
*Bob talks indecipherable* W: No frames hack
B: cheating M: Ok, I just gotta get the grenade, I just gotta get a grenade out before the frames get bad
M: Come on I can't, oh the one time my lid is open I can't grab a fucking grenade before you assholes...
M: GOD, THERE GOES MY FRAMEZ!
*Mark utters randomly while Bob and Wade laugh*
M: Duh my god, where's it going? Not far enough.
*Wade continues laughing* B: Oh *explosion*
M: Imma lose, Imma lose my mind. Imma gonna lose my fucking mind
M: Where is hand simulator headquarters?
M: Cause I wanna have a word with the developers of this game
M: because I need to have a conversation with them B: Mark, Mark, Mark
M: WHAT
B: We should try a different map, ok.
M: NO sh- alright fine let's do, yea
M: Yes, I agree
M: That is a sound argument B: NOOO
W: I got it, let's go fishing. M: let's go fishing, that sounds great W: Nice calm fishing
M; That sounds peaceful
B: Oh sweet jesus M: Oh, what is this?
B: God, jeez, fuck M: What iS tHIs?
W: Hey I see you Bob
B: Hi W:where's Mark
M: I'm right here, I can't even grab my pole, I'm here
B: I see you Mark, he's behind you, he's behind you M: I'm behind you
W: Oh, I can't face him, oh hand on, hand on, hand on, we're gonna restarts, we're gonna restart
W: Fix it for Mark B: Right, right, right. That'll fix it, that'll fix it
M: it's just a nice relaxing fishing adventure
B: Oh fuck, do you have to bait the hook? W: You sure do.
B: everything is- oh no, oh boy, M: What if I can't grab my pole? It just rolled off my lap
M: What I can't reach my pole
M: It rolled off my lap
W: Just keep on going, you're good
M: Guys I di- din- No I can't reach it, it's not reachable
B: You'll get it, you'll get it. Relax
M: No I'm not gonna reach it. Hong on, o wait here we go, here we go
W: Yea you're good, man, you're good
M: This doesn't make any sense. Guys you don't understand it not grabbing it.
W: Oh yea M: Wait don't oh yea me
M: It's not grabbing it B: You'll get it, you'll get it, just keep doing it
M: It's not, I'm clipping right through the thing... It just went further
M: It just went further, how did... W: You'll get it.
M: No I'm not gonna get it, it's not getting it.
B: it's not, you're not doing it right
M: I'm doing it exactly right, I'm going
B: Keep trying it, keep trying it M: I AM TRYING IT
M: I am trying it. It's not going. There's no way
M: I can't It's not physically grabbing it.
M: It's too far. W: Oh GOD OH GOD
W: Ok guys we gotta restart I lost my pole
M: No What Oh- you lost your pole. *meanwhile Bob laughs*
M: Oh we have to restart because you lost your pole
W: A yea the boat ate my pole. I didn't just drop it
M: NO I- B: Yea I think out of fairness Mark- I think we should restart
M: I DIDN'T DROP MY POL-
*Bob and Wade laugh*
M: Thank you, thank you, ya know what I'm gonna assume you did this for me.
M: cause my pole was clear- got it. Ok, I got it.
M: My pole is- B: Don't loss the pole bud M: I would never
B: Wade was having real trouble with that last time
M: No, I don't lose poles W: Out of fairness, if we lose our poles, we should probably restart
M: No, No, No, No, cause of what I had to endure. If you lose a pole it's your own dumb fault
M: THAT YOU'RE DUMB
W: Maybe if you wanted to make the rules you should have hosted the server
M: I Would have, I probably would have had good frames
W: B-but with your frames I don't wanna risk Bob and I have some bad quality.
*Mark sighs* B: That's true, that's true
W: Just trying to think of the greater good hear
M: Why did we agree to do this? This whole thing, this whole day.
M: This whole streaming thing, Why'd we agree?
M: Everything was perfectly fine in my life
W: ...My frames are good M: Why am I dabbing?
M: Why does the hand drift? It should be staying still.
M: Right, that's a logical thing?
W: Yea, my hand drifts too, I don't- why does only two of the fingies work
M: Got a fucking thing. Whatever this is
W: this is a larva? B: Did you really get a bait? What the fuck, how?
M: yes I got a bait- NO, no, no, no, no, no, no, please
M: Don't wanna drop my pole
B: How do you grab the fucking thing?!
M: No, no, no, no B: ♪no, no, no, no♪
B: ♪no no no♪ M: don't make fun of me
M: Don't make fun of me
M: No. no, no, no,
M: No. NO, it's on the precipice of DESTRUCTION
W: I don't know how you bait , how do you bait?
M: Oh I dropped a larva
W: How do you master this?
*Bob laughs*
M: gu, gu
M: guys... B; You having some kind of trouble Mark? M: My camera just locked into place
M: I can't move my head anymore
W: Oh wait... B: Why is my arm drifting?!
W: We have a rando, we have a rando M: I know we have a rando- (A wild Rando appears!) R: Oh shish! Wait is that Mark?
M: Oh fuck off
B: All my fucking progress I made, Noooo
W: Now it's up, I'm in
M: I'm in. B: It's surgery you fucker!
B: What? W: You didn't change yours
M: What what?
W: You'll have to change it on your end *groan*
M: All right
B: Fucking damn it
W: Hey don't you blame me for your guys frames
M: I- my frames are fine now
M: They got all better.
M: THEY WENT TO FRAME HOSPITAL TO GET SOME FRAME MEDICINE
W: Drugz?!?!
M: Oh W: Drugs?
W: Frame drugs? B: Who is that? I see Mark to my left, where's Wade?
W: Wait, Wade W: I'm to your far left M: Wade for my frames, restart the game
B: Oh no fishing pole!
B: I lost my fishing pole, restart the gam-ok
W: alright
M: Ok, I got an idea
W: Oh wait I see…
M: No, what the hell?
M: No x5
M: Ah Wade, my frames are still bad. Can you give it a little good old restart?
W: Ah, not for frames, I think, I think...
M: My- Wade come on. Don't you want everyone to have a good experience?
M: Just please give it a really good ol' resdardt?!?!
W: All right. Last one though
M: Ok *Mark laughs*
B: God damn it
M: It was my frames. My frames were so bad. I just couldn't...
M: Couldn't do that
W: Give me your worms
W: That sounds weird
M: No it doesn't
B: Give me your worms
M: That's perfectly normal
W: I can't, I can't, I can't,
M: I can't, I can't, I can't, no I can't,
M: I just can't do it guys
W: Yea know what? Ya know with that mockery, whenever you start to make progress...
W: I can see you, if I see you starting to make progress I'm restarting
M: Oh yea whatever. Yea know what. I'm never gonna make progress, jokes on you
M: stupid, *phew*, idiot. What were you thinking?
M: DuMmY
M: It's just- Why- It's like these bait, they just don't grab
M; there's no grabbing them. they, they, they're impossible
B: Is it physically possible to grab these fucking things? I don't understand
W: Why is the hook stuck on my oar?
W: Why's the hook stuck on my oar?
M: Why- I don't care why, I don't care why frankly. I don't where...
R: Hi guys, it's me again!
M: OH FUCK OFF!
*rando nonsense*
M: OH GO AWAY NO ONE CARES
W: All right we're leaving  *Mark groans*
M: Good God W: how?
W: Is this game like hacked? Cause how'd they get in there?
B: Probably M: Oh I don't know
W: All right well that was cool, do you guys wanna play a different game?
M: NO! I WANNA CATCH A FISH
M: I'M GONNA CATCH A FISH
M: And we're gonna, and I have, that's a game I have good frames
M: Alright, just cause, every time I grab for a bait...
M: I grab for a bait my frame drops.
If I get it, and I cast it, I'll be good. Lets try it again
B: Mark left the name out, says my chat
M: It'll be fine
M: I showed the name? I did show the name. I did show the name. that was me
M: That was me, I showed the name completely.
M: That was me, that was all on me.
M: And I take full responsibility for that
M; But listen, when I showed that name, I did it, I did it in full confidence that I could trust my fan base
M: Turns out that my fan base is full of...
M: A BUNCHA DOUCHEBAGS.
W: Alright so let's try not showing the secret game name. *Mark laughs*
M: Wait is there a new name?
W: YES
W: Would you like to say it out loud for you?
M: Yes
B: No, Wade, I think we need to restart for Marks frames
M: Wait I'm not even in, hang on.
*Bob laughs*
M: I just got in. B: Marks fishing pole is clipping through the boat
M: Is it?
B: YES M: Not on my end
M: Maybe your is loser
W: Oh I can't see Mark B: I think we need to restart for the frames
* evryone muttering in agreement*
M; All right B: Restart for his frames W: Frames
M: Restart for my frames specifically
W: Frames got it.
M: That didn't count as me calling for restart for my frames
W: Alright mark can't call for another restart
M: No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no
B: Bob called a restart and, and, and his frames were very bad, I kmow
W: Well I wasn't going to restart for Bob yet but you said I needed to restart
M: No, no, no, no, no,
M: I- I- I didn't say that
M; You, you're a liar
W: Oh, well too bad the liar is the host
W: Cause I think Mark already used up B: ah I need to restart for my frames
M: That's his framesX3 W: Alright now that both restart are done
M: No x10. No he called for his frames
M: And he called for my frames
M: I can still call for your frames,  for Bobs frames *Bob shouts* M: and my own frames still
B: God fucking fuck. W: I need to restart for my frames
*Mark laughs*
B: goddamn it
B: Seriously though. Is there some kind of trick to like grabbing a bait?
B: Cause I'm literally just tossing them around M: I can not figure it out for the life of me
W: Me either, I don't know how- half my fingers don't work
M: Woh! I got locked in head mode again
M: I don't know how it happened.
W: Shift gets you out of it.
M: No I'm doing that, no I'm going that.
W; Click the middle mouse button and it goes to head mode
M: No, I know, I didn't do it. I was grabbing a bait and suddenly I'm in head mode
M: And if I click middle mouse button... W: You messed up
M: I didn't', Can I call a restart for my frames...
B: God no, not like this
M: Ok, wait, no hang on, I'll figure it out
M: I'll figure W: Ok we need to restart frames. Mark, you asked for it.
B: Oh no *Mark laughs*
B: Man if you don't get the fishing pole you're fucking, you're fully boned
M: That's what I keep saying
W: Oh shit on a shitter fuckers I got one
M: Shit on a shitter.
B: Please don't talk to me like that
W: Oh, oh Daddy Papa I've got something- NO, MY POLE!
*Mark laughs*
B: No more frame restarts. No more frame restarts.
M: Ok W: Fine, fine M: Ok
W: I got it. I got my pole. I managed to recover my pole
W: WHY IS MY ARM GOING THROUGH MY BODY!?!!
W: WHY THE FUCK!??!
WHY IS THIS HAPPENING
B: I feel better about what's happening in my life
M: Yea I'm pretty good, I'm I'm- OH
M: OH, guess who got bait on his hook *Wade screams in agony in the background*
M: Oh god B: No, no, no
B: Oh no, oh no, W: Alright ah, frames M: yes x5
M: No restarting for frames, No restarting for frames!
M: No frames are fine W: No I gotta restart for frames
M: Frames are fine. B: Oh Fuck
M: Frames are fine W: I lost my frames, I lost my pole
M; FRAMES ARE FINE
M: I'VE NEVER HAD BETTER FRAMES
m: fRAMES ARE THE BEST THEY'VE EVER BEEN
B: I swear to god I just can't- fuck it M: Such good frames
B: Every time I get it into a position where I can grab it-
B: It flies away W: Mark your bait is gone
M; No it's not it's there. What No.
M: Where'd I go? x4
M: I have no frames. Frames are bad. Where's my? where did it go?
M: Everything's bad? You got it buddy!
M: Where's it- What do you mean? WHAT?!
*Dramatic music plays* M: NNOOOOOOO
W: Alright everyone heard Mark say his frames were bad
M: NOOOOO *Bob laughs*
B: You asshole
M: NOOOO NNNOOOOO
M: NNNNOOOOOOOOO
M:NNOOOO
W: First of all you'd already lost your bait
W: It was not on your hook
M; No, it was fine, it was there
W: Both of your arms were gone
M: Don't trust your screen of what my situation is
W: You called for frames M: I- W: Just wanted to help you as quickly as possible...
M: I DID NOT.
M: YOU. BETRAYED ME!
M: I was fine. I was so happy
B: Wow, what the fuck?
B: I got that thing that happened to Mark where my head got locked again
M: Yea it happened to me too. I think
M: I think Wade's doing something B: I can't do anything. I think Wade's cheating
M: Yea I can't do anything either
W: Oh wait B: I can't move W: Mine just did that too
M: Yea I think this game is broken
W: Alright let's call for a restart for frames
B: Oh god *Mark laughs*
M: It's just- It's when people grab too aggressively in the bait jar for some reason I think
M: Like for some reason...
W: you can't bait too aggressively inthis boat
M: You gotta bait real tenderly -like
M: I just gotta, ooh B: Oh Mark
M: Oh x3 *Bob laughs*
M: I've got it. W: Yes! M: Got it
M; It's - it's in the water B: No, Mark, your bait fell off
M: No it did not. No, it did not.
B: It did. It did I saw it M; I saw it B; I watched it
M: I saw- It's still there. It's still there
B: Ok, it's just- I can't see the bait on my end then.
B: Cause you have a naked hook on my end
M: I've got it. It's good. It's fine. Don't restart
W: Oh I'm not. I've got a bait, on a hook...
B: I hate all of you
W: We're just gonna calm the fuck down everybody
M: I'm calm
M: I'm calm W: Stay calm
W: Stay fucking calm,. M: I am calm
W: stay fucking calm! M: I'm calm
W: Yes B: You're cum?
W: come on, come on, come on, M: I'm cum. I'm cum
M: I'm cum B: You're cum?
W; Oh- bite that shit, god damn it
B: Wade, ah, what you do in your bedroom is really none of our business
B: Ok, calm down M: Oh, yea, bite that shit
M: Oh bite it off
M: Oh yea get it, swallow it whole W: Bite that shit while I bait
M: oh frame
M: oh yea frames
W: The bobber, I think, goes completely under. Mine's bouncing  right now, mine's
bouncen
B: naaahhh
M: Mine's bouncing. Mine's bouncing. Mine's bouncing.
M: Mine;s bounc- oh
Fish: o hai goodbye lol
M: Oh, oh, wait
M: NNOOOOOOOO!!! It was there!!! I saw the fish!!
M: NNNOOOOOOOOOOO W: It stole my bait!! It stole my bait!!!!
W: Fuck everything!!!!
M: OOOHHHHHHH W: Fuck you! Fuck this, pole! Goddammit
M:OOHHHHHH *Bob laugh*
W: Fuck you pole!!
W: Fuck everything B: That was the worst throw ever *Wade growls*
W: Alright Bob... B: I think I feel- ha
*Mark and Bob laugh*
B: I think I feel better about my position in all of that
M: Hang on, it's like, it's fine
M: It's- listen, Bob. You were doing real good
M: Ah, restart for frames. *Mark laughs*
B: Oh for god-
M: Oh god if you- W: Alright I've got one baited
M: If you explode your bait...
M: It just locks you in this position of being in looky mode
B: Oh, are you locked again? M: yup
M: I am so locked W: Fuck it, alright fine
M: Frames?? I dropped my- M: Is that a-
B: NNOOOOOO! God damn you!! *Mark laughs*
M: Yes I- *inserted applause M: Good job Wade, good call, good call, good call
M: When you need frames, you frame it up.
W: I never said the word frames M: oh, Wade frames, Wade frames please.
M: Wade frames please. Frames please
M; Frames please W: Oh my god B: No, no, no
B: No, no fishing pole calm down, well M: Frames
M: Ok that's the last frames
W: Oh ok o you can call it five times in a row B: God fu-
B: would you just fucking W: five time in a row
B: I hate you. Frames
*Mark laughs* B: Frames, I get frames. If Mark Gets Frames I Get Frames
B: *Gasp*  Oh! Oh! It's Gone!
B: NO, EVERYONE SHUT UP, I'M THINKING *Marks laughs*
B: Ha W: Is this frames?
M: no no B: No no, DON'T you FUCKING DARE!
*Wade laughs* B: I Will- NOOOOOOOOO
B: It's fine
B; Everything's fine W: was that frames?
M: No, no frame call!
M: Who's calling for frames?!
M: Who's doing it? Nobody W: Oh frames, frames~
M: No no no frames!
M: No frames B: No No No No
M: Don't you dare W: Oh no I got head locked
W: Frames XD B: No No No M: don't frames, don't frames no
M&B: No
W: Frames! M: Don't!
M: Frames
W: FRAAMEZ! M: No!
B: No W: Frames! B: You assholes made me watch! You Assholes Made Me Watch!
M: My bait! (almost cries)
M: I'm fine. No frames, no frames, no frames
W: FRAMES M: NO DON'T FRAMES
W: That's two people yelling frames. Bob frames.
M: I was yelling mames B: NO
M: I was yelling splames
W: I broke it
M: So? B: No one cares!
B: It's your own fault W: I'm the server host so I care. I have powers
B: God made you this way
*mark laughs*
M: I have become one with this bait
M: It is entered my han- and it's fallin out
B: Come on, W: Is that- Is that- is that frames? B: NO
M: No B: I will destroy your entire family
*Mark uses baby talk*
M: Mr pole, who wants a delicious... W: come here
M: maggot
B: come here and be friends W: Frames
B: NO God M: No don't do it!
W: I've not gotten a frames yet!
M: No you- B: You guys made me watch for like five minutes!
W: It's been five minutes
M: yea well, B: No it has not M: Yea well
SHUDDAP
W: Frames M: No no B: God fuck it
M: No it's pirouetting. It's pirouetting!
M: the bait is pirouetting!
M: How's it doing that!?  B: I can't tickle it anymore W: Because it's a frames
M: NO it's not a frames!
M: It's going in glorious 60FPS
M: It's no frames
M: it's - I don't
M: No it's - W: No frames! Mark said no frames
M: I have plenty of frames
M: I need frames *laughs*
B: No, nooo- W: Bob that's' two votes frames
*Bob laugh* M: Noooo B: Alright fine
*mark groans* B: fine W: Alright frames
M: Oh W: I've got frames
M: Bait has been achieved
*Bob mutters vigorously with anger*
W: You ok Bob B: No No No no no no
B: you stay over here
M: you've become an old southern man in your age
*In a gruff southern accent* B: Come on bait, come on ou worm fuckers...
B: Just a please a come on...
B: No not like this baby... listen
B: She didn't mean anything...
B: Ugh it's always been about you *Wade laughs*
B: Come on please... M: I'm not sure I li-
B: I don't wanna divorce...
B: nah ple- what about the children?...
B: A come on we can work it out. We can go to couples therapy...  W: Bob are you ok?
B: It's fine...
B: it's fine... M: I have bait on rod
*suddenly not southern, just crazy* B: all the voice, all the voices M: I have achieved rod bait
B: In your head- everything's fine...
M: Ok it's in the water, it's in the water
*back to normal I think* B: I Hate This. I Hate This!
B: how are you guys doing?
M: I almost- I need utter concentration
M: I don't care about your divorce proceeding W: Frames?
M: No, no frames B: did he say frames?
M: No one said anything about frames
M: Please just let me have this one.
M: I got I gOt - I GOT A FISH *victory soundeffects*
M: I GOT A FISH
B: No M: I GOT A FISH! I caught a fish
B: Holy fuck M: It's it- do I have to grab it? Do I have to grab it? W: Yes
W: You've got to get the fish off the hook M: Oh God No!
M: Ok ok I got- *Music swells*
M: My hand, my hand is in. Oh it's too far B: oh no
M: No, no, no, no, no, no OHHHHH
*W&B laugh*
M: JUST LET ME HAVE THIS ONE. IT'S A BIG BOY
*Bob laughing* M: It's such a big boy
W; get it M: It's such a big boy. I'm gonna get it
M: I'm gonna get it
M: I'm going for the grab
M: hu, I almost had it that time
*B&W laughing* M: Ho, come on. Peak a boo
M: Peak a boo. Peak a boo. Peak a boo.
M: ok catch it on the SWING
M: OHH come on
M: Give me you. YES! I have it
M: What do I do with it!?!? W: alright, frames, frames
M: I have it. What do I do?!
M: what do I do with it?! Do I put it in my box?
M: How do I get it off the hook?
W: I don't know, I've never made it that far. B: You should definitely let go of your pole
M: Ok I'm gonna-
*Super Mario World level complete jingle plays* *Mark screams*
W: Mark got it. B: God damn it W: Mark got a fish
*Bob snickers*
W: I was so close to restarting it
M: If you would have restarted I would have flown to Cincinnati to slap you
M: I would have flown. I would have done it
M: My whole chats just like restart
M: Oh, oh my god
W: Well we never had to play this game again, now do we? *outro fades in*
M: NO B: Yea are we done with this now M: Yea
M: Yea I think we're done W: thank god
*♪outro♪* (Subscribe to caption authors!)